but behind the scenes in his everyday
life
jalen brown long three-pointer gets it
to go
celtics allen's white side nurkich that
canter
can have an impact as jason tatum knocks
down the shot
remember the days when you can play twin
talus
everybody did tatum for three
that's good anthony against tatum
gets down low blocked by tatum back out
hezonja mccullum an open three won't
fall
an excellent start for the boston
celtics
tatum another three jason tatum
wouldn't be worried about you struggling
anyways allow me to have this dance
allows him to sleep long distance
knocked down him
tatum finds room elbow jumper that's
good six percent we're just past the
midway point of the second
tatum again his from three-pointer
and already with 17 points to him in the
right spot and gave him space to work
with
jalen brown off balance falling away
shots good
and won everything going down for the
boston celtics
carmelo anthony spotting up hayward gets
her wanting start throws it ahead to
jalen brown for the flush
[Applause]
and it's back to 20. with plenty of
energy
an incredible comeback tatum brown
jalen brown answers and ties the game
lillard way outside oh my goodness
that's just a couple of feet inside to
have court mark as brown throws it down
brown still plenty of time remaining
[Music]
tatum at 21 first half points drives
inside banks and holds
in the foul he's got 30 as well away and
makes a play
patience blows them to sleep because of
his shot making you got to honor that
the late brown you know you make the
case be the third best player with kemba
healthy
love his attitude